after the United States it's the next
most powerful army in the world and it's
growing under Vladimir Putin Russia's
military spending has soared in 2012 the
Kremlin became the third highest spender
on defense worldwide by
2016 spending will approach a hundred
billion doar more than Germany and
France combined that coupled with
Russia's annexation of Crimea and
fighting in eastern UK Ukraine has got
NATO rattled the climate is volatile a
new report points to 40 events in
2014 that it says could push the
standoff into a direct conflict between
Russia and NATO Russia is sending a
political message of intimidation saying
that uh it uh would not uh stand by uh
while NATO is increasing its footprint
uh along the r border with military
bases in Syria and dotted across the
former Soviet Union Russia's muscle is
not what it was in Soviet day but it is
growing and is increasingly seen by NATO
as a
threat